what is the most ridiculous thing about
your game press X to pay respect oh god
yeah that was F to respects I can't
believe that made it in the game is is
embarrassing this is versus the GameSpot
show that pits your favorite games
consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against one another this week
we'll go into war as we pit over
franchises battlefield and Call of Duty
against one another arguing the case for
Call of Duty as well Potter who once
strove to three separate branches of
Sainsbury's trying to look for a copy of
modern warfare 2 he later bought it
again for 3 pound 50 just last week and
fighting for battlefield is Dave Jewett
you got this excited when talking about
battlefield 5 on camera so much so
excited about damn each going to argue
the corner for their game over the
course of three randomly selected topics
with the overall winner being decided by
you the wonderful viewers last week's
battle royale between pub G &
fortnight's will Dave defeat me and pub
G with 57% of the vote for his fortnight
arguments but it's an absolute disgrace
and I demand a recount anyway it's about
on this episode we're going to be
throwing up a clickable poll right here
on YouTube vote for who you think I'll
give that case better by clicking on the
little I in the top right corner at any
point during the video and casting your
vote or if you're watching this on
gamespot comm let us know you think is
won the debate in the comment section
below
right let's get into the debate
[Music]
I booked Dave we meet again yeah a bit
your less time than night all right look
you may know a lot about first-person
shooters so I am a bit nervous going
into this cuz you know your stuff we've
got a loot box what looks like a big box
yes we all know you should like falling
from the sky like burst open and three
cards Wow legendary have I got a shiny
gun right gameplay well I think battle
has the superior gameplay from ecology
has always been it's just an arcade
arena where as for me battlefield has
core of our games the shooting way more
down in quality leaders but bow filled
every gun has a different muzzle
velocity has different drop has
different range things like sniping is
is way more satisfying because you
actually have to line up a shot aim way
above their head or like range your
target and then you get to see the
bullets go whereas if your corner Duty
player you just left trigger right
trigger quick scope hit marker dead but
I don't have been doing maths while I'm
playing a game it matters aim above them
well you sounds like you're doing like
geometry or whatever trigonometry I
failed maths so I fell of GE go G is
like a roller coaster
it's it funnels you down this exciting
par and it feels so immersive and I
think because it's like a roller coaster
you you're just in for the ride I'm a
bit more casual than you in terms of
shooters right I'm not thinking about
was it muzzle velocity I don't even know
what that is it sounds complicated if I
just yeah I just want to shoot stuff
have a good time it's so immersive and
you feel that you are there with your
squad with the troopers whether it's I'd
completely disagree I think battlefield
way more immersive and you use the
roller-coaster analogy if country's
rollercoaster battlefield is the entire
theme park it's got way more rides way
more attractions the maps are enormous
the average battlefield map they'll be
distance ranges that you can have long
distance engagements they'll be
buildings that you can do close quarters
combat
you have vehicles that you can engage
with land sea and air that's three extra
rides in my theme park than just your
poxy rollercoaster and your back garden
yeah but in battlefield you spend so
much time wandering around and you get
slapped in the head and you don't know
where it was problem have to spend your
time wandering around if you want to go
into the hills and get your ghillie suit
on and snipe then yeah go run around but
if you want to get close quarters into
the action then you squad up you work
with your team you go in and play the
objective like that the term PT fo
exists in battlefield
no one says play the [ __ ] objective
in college okay battlefield you have
objectives and you're rewarded for
pursuing these objectives and you feel
driven to pursue these objectives and
when you have like 64 people in a map
and you've got 31 other teammates just
storming this objective all at once it's
like it sounds wanky but it does feel
quite epic from what I've played a
battlefield I just end up trying to do
that and then I get attached from my
squad or I'm I think it is too awful
I think Call of Duty is way more quick
and fun and anyone can pick up and play
and you don't have to worry about you
know you can play with a team if you
want to and yeah you'll do better but if
you just want to run around shooting
your m16 yeah you can do that and that's
the fun next topic single-player I've
got this in the bag surely I mean you
are a single player I actually play
mostly single-player for collegiate
games you've got everything from world
war two campaigns landing on d-day and
playing collegiate world war two was
emotional you know you're a constantly
reminded that this happened and it's
respectful in the single-player if you
press F yeah but I think from the
characters to the setting to the
missions
I think Cora Duty has it so much better
than in battlefield there are so many
memorable moments from college campaigns
like no russian which shocked everyone
and you've got like the nuke dropping in
warfare what they were up to infinite
warfare which I loved it basically had
the plot of Mobile Suit Gundam which you
know I love you had a robot companion
and I think that robot companion was
better than any character in any
battlefield game like he was funny he
was this like deaf machine who also
cracked jokes I'm sorry I think I think
collegiate you have hands down has this
one so you really think ecology has
really good campaigns yeah that good
that's the question for a later video I
hope they're not gone forget I hope we
see more campaigns in future
what about battlefield like does anyone
actually play the campaign yeah I've
really enjoyed the campaigns in
battlefield the battlefield war stories
from bf one were actually staggering
okay each one of them was like a small
World War one movie the characters were
written really well it wasn't
constrained by one single area or
character or a piece you get like a
whole smorgasbord of all these worlds
one one experiences but battled has also
shown that it has multiple feathers in
its cap it's done a comedy in the
battlefield bad company series that's
had some some of the best action-packed
moments and some of the best comic
relief characters it's the variety in
battlefield and I know a lot of people
in the back it's battlefield they don't
come to the campaign yeah it's still
trying to craft its own story I think is
very respectable and then our new one
has single-player so that's the V in
Butterfield V I I mean yes battlefield
has had some good moments but I think
consistently and actually historically
going back to the first call of duty
it's had that campaign experience and
it's had World War two it's had
Vietnam it's had Modern Warfare which is
which came up just a few years after
like this it's a very post 9/11 game and
threat felt so real that that's what
made the game feel very much like yes
this is like believable this is bad feel
tackled similar similar things it was it
was still in the same mindset that a lot
of the more modern Call of Duty games
were and I think it it created that
intimacy
in in the squad that you had and it was
much more of a tactical approach but you
don't have a funny robot or a man called
soap we don't have a man called soap
there's mr. McTavish to you Oh
[Music]
multiplayer should have seen that coming
I mean I think battlefield easily takes
multiplayer just for the fact that it's
got way more than called a GE has
probably ever will
the original battlefield 1942 is
considered one of those like roughly
famous games that changes or drives
forward as genre it managed to give 64
players at any one time this amazing
battlefield sandbox he expanded into the
modern day with battlefield 2 I have
still fond memories about a feel to you
of these massive squad fights engineers
destroying bridges then our team
engineers trying to repair bridges or
lay down new ones we can get tanks
across there's a reason why there's that
term like battlefield moments because
there's there's certain things in
battlefield multiplayer that can only
happen in battlefield this just an
incredible amount of variety and I've
never got that from call of duty there's
a reason why I had hundreds of hours in
battlefield 3 because that was one of
the that's one of the crowning FPS games
to me it changed so much and it brought
so much so like the the first person
shooter table it was just unbeatable for
me the other reason you spent hundreds
of hours playing that game is because it
takes so long to learn and it's it's way
more sort of complicated and difficult
to play and it's not as accessible as
ecology after that glorious
single-player campaign that you've just
finished which was glorious by the way
which one we're talking about any of
them you go into multiplayer which was
my tradition I would finish the campaign
same right same boy player time I've
learned all the skills I need to fill
multiplayer and right off the bat it's
quick it's close its intimate ecology
multiplayer is so much more
of quick and and a more rewarding I
think like you name some good moments
about battlefield but I think they're
few and far between I like earning
things quicker and I like constant
rewards because I'm a child I like that
donar
don't there when you rank up and you're
like you're a sergeant now you've got
this cool new camouflage pattern for
your weed on your shotgun yeah man I'm
gonna have 360 noscope and you would
never 360 noscope down on your life no
you are rewarded so often in Call of
Duty that I feel like I am not wasting
my time playing I've dropped into
battlefield matches run around the
desert for ages and then got shot in the
head off the five minutes alright well
that wasn't very fun that's cuz your
rents was the flag though no pcfo was
designed for people like okay I'm going
to pull out my ace card zombies so you
can put play called a G just for that I
put many hours into all of the zombie
mode and I'll greed you I played kino
der toten like anything else as well but
that's all my zombies here bill it's
part of multiplayer so we have a look
about it you can't just say our battle
doesn't have it it could be also
particle pain myself true UAV all night
yeah see we don't need your spot and use
our god-given sights I bet you're up
just feeling like this like I'm gonna
select someone from approximately 3
kilometres with my so-and-so gun that's
too far it's ridiculous
look you're the one that does all the
maxing game so yeah whatever I don't
care I just got cool guns like digital
camo every six year olds shouting about
sleeping with your parents I can meet
them our biggest year so the final
takeaway from that is that Dave likes
Mass and will gets very abused online
but more importantly who do you think
won the debate let us know by voting in
our poll and top right corner of the
video or if you're over on Gamescom by
putting your thoughts in the comment
section below
it'd be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves hurt right time for
this week's quick fire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how will and
they've gone what is the most ridiculous
thing about your game press x to pay
respect oh god yeah that was
two respects that was I can't believe
that made it in the game is is
embarrassing frankly being a being able
to put two two fellows with flame throws
on a horse I was pretty cool then they
lick you this hyper-realistic
yeah that's what that's why I like do an
impression of your favorite gun and I'll
do the m1 grand it goes yeah it goes
okay anyone put it in the thing with it
while that was my last shot
what is the windiest phrase publishers
slash developers have used to describe
your franchise I mean the LEvolution is
still like one of the shittiest buzz
words go in I do not want to hear boots
on the ground ever again I'm so sick I
wouldn't even wear this anymore which
franchise would win in office away day
paintball fight pow field but there's
more of you there's more of you yeah but
called SWAT teams
well accurate SWAT versus actual Marines
like you don't need numbers you just
need a small squad go in precision
headshots around what Special Forces
work in office this is a hypothetical
scenario it's 64 of us against your what
12 so we need I've seen the film three
hundred guns the Persians are guns they
also lost a great fighter lost the count
really remember to get your voice heard
in our poll or in the comment section
below and tell us who you think argue
their case better and if you enjoyed
this episode of vs. make sure to hit
that subscribe button as we'll have new
episodes of the show every Wednesday
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you